[Musique]
on lem croustillantes à l'extérieur
moelleuse et aromatiques à l'intérieur
moi ce que je préfère je pars avec ma
baguette à la fin de la journée et puis
je peux manger avec tout et du fromage
que pour sow c'est pour n'importe quoi
pour moi c'est mon préféré
mathieu l'hommelet maîtres boulangers à
la bête appelle ici la baguette et au
nar pour moi il faut qu'elles soient
bien cuites pour vraiment que la croûte
soient croustillantes au niveau de
l'odeur fonction de froment il faut une
demie à l'intérieur qui est qui et
calvet au les cas beaucoup de trous en
fin de compte et bien aéré pour qu'elles
soient légères en bouche pour la manger
[Musique]
on aimerait tous avoir comme voisin un
artisan boulanger mais la plupart
d'entre nous achetons notre baguette à
l'épicerie les ventes continuent
d'augmenter on a de plus en plus de
demandes
françois croteau et responsable en
boulangerie chez provigo le pain
provient de la boulangerie ontarienne
est ce qui appartient weston qui est
aussi le propriétaire du provigo dans le
fond lorsqu'on les reçoit nous écoute a
presque 90%
on reçoit nos produits dans des cases
surgelés lorsqu'on a besoin de produits
on prend le produit en mai sur des tôles
on l'envoie au faux en moins de 15
minutes une baguette fraîche chaude à
proférer nos clients ailleurs les
baguettes arrive également congelés chez
métro ses premières moissons qui leur
appartient qui fabrique les baguettes en
user quant à iga
elle achète de pain doré une marque de
l'industriel brille dans leur baguette
ressemble à celle des artisans mais
répond-t-elle aux critères qui
définissent ce qu'est une bonne baguette
nous avons acheté une douzaine de
baguettes blanche fraîche du jour
nous les avons présentés à marie-pascale
bonne enseignante en boulangerie
artisanale mario fortin qui collabore
avec de nombreux industriels de la
boulangerie et gérons ferrer chef
exécutif du restaurant europea l'ultime
lag est pour moi l a3 couleur va du
caramel jusqu'à la torréfaction avec des
pas bon goût de grillé sur ce qu'on
appelle les lignes donc higgins et des
petites oreilles qu'on retrouve en sur
le pain elle l'a une croûte qui est
relativement mince très croustillantes
elle a de belles alvéoles à l'intérieur
une belle micky est légèrement brillante
couleur crème par la voiture sigean par
le crépitement l'odeur un petit peu
presque sucrée vallier deux semaines à
je vais commencer à y aller pour le
breton et je commence à piocher dedans
si j'ai déjà ramené mon père la maison
amoché sex-symbol
[Rires]
on choisit avec les yeux d'abord je
m'imagine en épicerie voir les baguettes
[Musique]
certaines baguettes sont éliminés sur le
champ il y en a une vraiment qui
m'interpelle immédiatement c'est celle
ci non pas par sa qualité visuelle au
contraire non c'est pas toi c'est pour
ces packs sa table effectivement mais
trois maguette ont retenu leur attention
moi j'irais là 10 à 12 la set up
il a trois
[Musique]
c'est la numéro 10 qik qui m'offre le
plus de 2 de jouissance en bouche avec
la texture croquante le goût qui est
agréable sont toutes bonnes femmes les 3
j'aime beaucoup la cité de la numéro 3 à
3 pour moi quand même une bonne
fermentation les miens a violé les
autres ressentent certains coins qui
sont plus dans un petit peu mais les
toits définitivement manque de cuisson
lama roche c5 en caoutchouc et non
croque là ça devrait être comme moi ce
que je trouve rassurant c'est l'allié
des ingrédients et puis je vois qu'elle
est relativement courte de moins en
moins d'additifs
on retrouve beaucoup de farine qui sont
non blanchi aussi le consommateur ne
peut être que gagnant
rappelons que la baguette artisanale est
faite de farine pétri avec de l'eau du
sel et de la levure les baguettes
d'épicerie contiennent parfois d'autres
interdits alors je maltais vienne vient
de la céréale l'orge et s'est usé pour
ajouter des gaz de fermentation dans la
parole qui est d'aller chercher des
alvéoles qu'on va avoir dans la mire le
dextrose est un choc très vain qu'on
utilise en vouloir sucrine baguette des
fois pour aller chercher une belle
couleur dorée plus rapidement et le cdh
ascorbique est un occident donc c'est en
vitamine c
ça aide aussi au développement au bout
ce ne sont pas toutes les baguettes qui
sont bien élevés au lait pour notre
artisan boulanger c'est pourtant un gage
de qualité pour vraiment voir le côté
algérie et bien aéré c'est ce qu'on
recherche puissent pas des bulles qui
sont pas régulières qu'est ce que ça
nous dit si les bulls ont régulière ou
irrégulière
lien ce tour on va vraiment aller
chercher une fermentation qui était bien
maîtrisée et donc forcément donc le goût
si on aime la fermentation on a du monde
c'est ce que voulant réussir un des
reproches que je ferais souvent d'un
gros volume de fabrication du pain au
québec c'est le pen qui est pas
suffisamment cuits contraire de
l'industrie selon nos experts en place
souvent la baguette chaud directement
dans le sac sans la laisser refroidir
ce qui crée de l'humidité est ramollie
la croûte peut-être consommateurs il ya
la fierté de le toucher immédiatement
dit un poil super le pain et les grosses
il est chaud mais rapidement il va venir
tout raplapla tout bon pour sauf chez
l'artisan on la met de gros mots qu'elle
reste bien conscient alors qu'à
l'épicerie on la voit souvent dans un
secteur où chaufferette patience car du
passé de la patience il faut aussi que
le consommateur
peut-être s'habitue acheter du pain qui
n'est plus chauds comme le pain est
sensible à l'humidité
nos experts recommandent de passer des
baguettes de supermarchés quelques
minutes au four à 400 degrés pour au
moins leur donner une croûte craquante
parmi les choix à faire bien qu'on soit
loin de la baguette d'artisans nos
panélistes ont apprécié les qualités de
la baguette reis de provigo suivi de
première moisson de métro et finalement
de plats doré européenne de iga centaine
à table il n'y a pas du voir et la
baguette pour moi c'est le temps idéal
parce que c'est un thème passe partout
qui peut aller de la petite entrée à
tartiner action jusqu au fromage et on
peut en faire tout un repas sur le
perdre
[Musique]